did you realize that over a billion people on this
planet are deficient in iron i was actually pretty
surprised to hear that so today we're going to
talk about iron deficiency anemia so here are
the symptoms fatigue pale like you're losing color
brittle nails you get those little grooves in your
nails hair loss thinning of the hair twitching
feeling irritation pica you crave dirt or clay
number nine you have the urge to consume ice or
chew on ice and number ten restless leg syndrome
now there's actually more but these are the main
ones now the question is what is causing this well
excessive menstruation okay excessive bleeding
and by the way if you're female and your cycles
are very heavy that means you have estrogen
dominance i'm going to put a link down below
for you to watch later but there's some things you
can do to reverse that problem number two ulcers
it could be an ulcer in the stomach or even the
small intestine that you don't even know about
number three hemorrhoids i have a very good video
on this um you want to support your liver there's
a really good remedy i also have a remedy on this
as well i'm going to put the link down below it's
involving taking zinc number four colon cancer
could potentially cause anemia number five dietary
you're a vegan and you're only consuming beans
and grains and plants those food have what's
called non-heme iron and you only absorb a
very very small amount it's like 1.4 percent
of the iron so you'd have to consume a tremendous
amount of plants to get your iron the problem is
a lot of the plants and grains have certain
things like oxalates or phytates that block iron
the best source of bioavailable iron is
called heme iron is from seafood red meat
poultry eggs and even insects have a high level
of heme iron just in case that you may get that
urge you know late at night if you want a snack
and i'm being very sarcastic all right number six
certain antibiotics can deplete you of iron number
seven low stomach acid a lot of people have this
they don't even know it as you age you lose the
stomach acid and now you cannot absorb certain
minerals especially iron and even calcium number
eight malabsorption if you have some type of
problem in your colon or you're missing
a gallbladder or you had surgery as in
gastric bypass that can leave you with a hard
time absorbing iron and number nine and this
is fascinating i'm going to create a separate
video just on this but inflammation can deplete
your iron how well both good bacteria and
bad bacteria as in pathogens need iron to
grow and what happens within your immune system
your body as well as your good bacteria tend to
lock up or bind iron during an infection during
a fever and during inflammation so what happens
as a survival mechanism your body prevents the
pathogens from getting a hold of the free iron
and that is one strategy to help limit their
growth now what's supposed to happen is after
the infection the inflammation goes away but
what happens if you have chronic inflammation
because you have some type of autoimmune
condition rheumatoid arthritis lupus or
whatever that is going to end up depriving your
whole body of a lot of trace minerals iron being
a very specific one and so the more chronic
the inflammation the more anemic you could be
now you might say well i'll just go ahead and
solve this problem by taking more iron right
well you're going to actually feed the pathogens
and then they can actually grow and you'll create
an imbalance so how do you solve that what
you do is you get rid of the actual source
of the inflammation there's a couple things that
i would recommend i'm gonna put the videos down
below but number one fasting periodic prolonged
fasting is essential and a lot of vitamin d
both of those can help reduce the inflammation
without adding in the iron for the pathogens
so now you know the symptoms and what causes
anemia and if you haven't seen my video on
chronic inflammation and anemia i'm going
to put it up right here check it out you